[Music]
[Applause]
he is Jason mccordi won a Super Bowl
with the Patriots done a great job as an
analyst for good morning football played
in the NFL for 13 Seasons you can see
him on good morning football Monday
through Friday at 7 a.m. eastern has
your opinion of Kirk Cousins changed
Jason after what we saw against the
49ers we tend to react from week to week
how about you I've always been a Kurt
Cousins fan and uh I go I go to bat for
him to the point where people keep
saying especially Minnesota fans where
it doesn't happen or they don't make the
play at the end of the game you think
back of last year they lose that playoff
game to the Giants just like we got to
get rid of Kurt Cousins I'm like and
you're replacing him with who and I
think every time those things start to
creep in Kurt Cousins goes out there and
he has a game like he had Monday night
against the 49ers where he was just
unbelievable but going to into that game
he led the NFL in touchdown passes so
it's not like he was just out there
slouching or in some type of slump and
he did that without Justin Jefferson so
my opinion of Kurt Cousins has been the
same he can play he hasn't won the big
game but he balls for them week in and
week out and then also uh his sense of
fashion is really poor so that hasn't
changed at all but it but it he should
be an Underdog Story it feels like when
he got that guaranteed contract people
turned on him like that's the guy who's
going to get the first all guaranteed
contract I mean he's what a fourth round
draft pick and he's done he's done a
pretty good job in his career no doubt
about it think about he was drafted to
be RG3's backup yeah and all of a sudden
next thing you know he's a starter in
Washington and as far as the guaranteed
contracts I look at it as well he
understood what the game was he
understood the market he understood what
his abilities to do and he had the
leverage and he went out and did it and
he continues to win when it comes to
comes to contracts being franchised
twice and getting a big deal from
Minnesota then signing again in
Minnesota and this upcoming offseason
he'll be a free agent whether the
Vikings bring him back or he is the open
market Kurt Cousins is going to be paid
again so he'll be able to buy all the
button-up dress shirts in the whole nine
uh that him and his wife Julie put
together Kurt Cousins has done it the
right way all give me the team that you
know exactly who they
are oh that's tough right now I mean
going in I would have thought the 49ers
and they lose backtack games the Eagles
you feel a certain way about if I had to
pick one I would sayy but it's like at
the same time there's question marks
with jayen Herz is thrown eight
interceptions he's tied with Garoppolo
leading the league right now and that's
not typical of what we've seen we've
seen up and down from the Cowboys there
really isn't a team right now that
you're just like I'm gungho this is the
number one team in the NFL is but the
Chiefs it feels like though jaay it just
we keep trying to an somebody MVP wise
or best team wise and it comes back
Kansas City and Patrick Mahomes and they
kind of fall under that LeBron James
thing where their greatness and their
level we go to expect it so much that to
your point we're waiting for the next
team to say all right the 49ers were so
good they're going to be the team to
beat and to your point Kansas City goes
out there they lose the first game of
the season to the Lions without Travis
Kelce without Chris Jones those two come
back they struggle offensively through a
few weeks and now they're right on
stride of the Kelce to Mahomes that
connection so you're absolutely right if
you had to pick one team you would save
them but it's like at the same time they
also feel beatable this year but for
whatever reason they find a way in every
single game uh to just win those games
whether it's a close score whether it's
a blowout um somehow they just become
the standard and they continue to do so
I don't know if you talked trash but you
probably had teammates who did if you
were facing uh Travis Kelce
would you bring up Taylor
Swift of course and the the crazy thing
is having played against Kelsey a ton
and attempting to talk trash and do all
those things I feel like he's well
prepared I mean this is a guy that
hosted Saturday Night Live so you're
going into the game you're thinking of
all the Taylor Swift things you can say
you may even bring Jason Kelce into it
and I feel like he's well prepared he's
already gone through it he already has
his comebacks his wit and all of that
ready but trying to stop Travis Kelce
you pull out whatever ever it is you can
you go back and you watch documentaries
you may be trying to bring up Ed Kelce
Donna Kelce the whole n you're trying to
throw the whole kitchen sink at him
because it felt like he had 25 catches
and 200 yards in just the first half of
the Chargers game this past weekend okay
I asked Marcus Spears this yesterday I
ask you you can have uh Tyreek Hill or
Jason
Kelsey Travis
K oh my goodness oh I'm going with
Tyreek Hill I'm a I'm a small guy I'm
I'm all four speed um Tyreek Hill leaves
Kansas City leaves Patrick Mahomes he
gets to Miami he goes to is one of the
most accurate passes I've ever been
around and you're like all right all
right Tyreek we get it like he's your
quarterback you gotta hype him up and
he's been absolutely fantastic in Miami
so I'm going Tyreek Hill and that's no
slight against Travis Kelce obviously
this guy's like fine wine he's getting
better with age but I think I'm going
Tyreek Hill especially because all the
antics never know what you're going to
get Jason well sometimes that's good and
bad Jason mccordi NFL Network and former
Patriot won a title there works for good
morning football on NFL Network better
tight end Kelsey or
grun oh longevity has to come into play
I'm going with Travis Kelce on that one
this guy is the same age as grank and he
is still doing it and it's not like all
right he's still playing he's
transitioning into a blocker or
something of that no he's still doing it
as the number one one receiver on the
Kansas City Chiefs the guy that they're
going in double teaming and trying to
stop week in and week out he's still
performing at a high level grank
obviously the better blocker different
styles but if I had to just pick one I'm
going Travis Kelson got any problem with
the uh the brotherly shove what's the
future of it I don't have a problem with
it uh Richard Sherman brought up a great
point on field goal blocks as a defense
you're not allowed to stand behind those
big linemen and push them and they say
that's for the health and safety of the
player so what's the difference
offensively great point but I don't know
there's just something fun about the
play something fun about the fact that
every other team is trying to do it we
watched Minnesota do it Monday night
Fred Warner jumps over the offensive
lineman and tackles Kurt Cousins which
was kind of allaha Troy palalo who did
it while I was standing on the sidelines
for the Titans he jumped over and
grabbed kry Collins there's something
about a play that nobody can stop that
makes it a lot of fun and you don't want
the the rules committee to come and then
put a stop to it so especially Nick
serani we we call him like a walking
emoji on good morning football and the
way he talks about it how proud he is
about it I love that fact so I'm hoping
the play stays in but I'm also hoping
that somebody comes along and finds a
way to stop it and Philly goes in the
game and goes 0 for three on fourth and
one trying to run that play did you ever
tackle Derrik
Henry no I was teammates with him his
rookie year and then in Tennessee we
played when I moved to New England we
played him once and I never got
one-on-one with him and um I was very
happy about that were you avoiding him
is that what you were doing by time that
was that was year 11 in the league so by
that time you learn how to make those
business decisions so you you stick on
the receiver a little bit longer I
remember his first team me he comes into
the to the meeting room and myself and a
safety Damen Stafford are sitting next
to each other and Derek is already
sitting when we walk in the meeting room
and rookies know you're supposed to
stand until the vets come in so he TAPS
in me like hey Rook you're in my seat
and Derek stands up and both of us just
look up at the sky and Damian was like
Hey man if I knew you were that big I
would just let you take the seat and I
would have somewhere else to sit so it's
it's crazy impressive his statua and how
he's built up as a running back okay
what are the Titans doing they've traded
away their best receiver the best
defensive back you're looks like you're
moving forward you with a another
quarterback in the draft
here do you think they should will trade
derck Henry I think if they can I think
they will trade Derrik Henry I think
it's a matter of what Contender possibly
somebody like maybe a Buffalo Bills who
obviously they have James Cook who's
more of a scat bat um speed like maybe
you add a Derk Henry I think if they can
get what they feel they deserve for a
Derk Henry I think they would trade him
I think Ryan tanah Hill would be on a
trading block if he was healthy I think
right now I remember talking to Rand
carthon in the summer and he said
building a roster is kind of like
renovating you're not just rebuilding
everything or resetting or starting over
you're keeping some of your antique some
of your really valuable pieces but
you're also trying to add some of those
pieces as well I think as the season is
progress Tennessee hasn't had as much
success as they want and somebody like
Kevin Bard became available for Philly
and it's like why not go out and make
that tree and byer's a guy they called a
mayor in Tennessee a guy that has built
bricks in that building has been
outstanding as a player and a man off
the field so I think he brings a lot to
Philly and Derek fits in that same boat
I think he could be on his way out can
find a trade partner as well great stuff
Jason as always we appreciate your time
enjoy you on good morning football with
the crew there thanks thanks again for
stopping by oh appreciate it thanks for
having me nice to be with a legend Jess
whoa oh did you guys think he was
talking about you guys yeah oh I think
he was talking about me nice to be with
Legends oh is that I thought but I am
Legend oh plural oh man maybe not I am
Legends Jason mccordi NFL Network good
morning football obviously he knows
Talent